foreign
anytime somebody says they're living the
dream they are for sure not living the
dream really struggling with motherhood
I love my kids
with everything for the rest of the show
you don't even have to repeat that
because I know that
[Music]
yo yo yo this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast ever ever that's ever
existed
so grateful you've joined us
if you want to be on the show we're
going to talk about what's going on in
your life what's going on in the life of
your spouse what's going on with your
person you're dating and your kids
whatever is going on this is a show for
you by you and about you it's real
people with real challenges and I'm
gonna pull up a pull up a chair and
we're gonna figure out what to do now
and moving forward so if you want to be
on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 you're
gonna leave a message and you can make
it as long as you want or as short as
you want but let us know what's going on
and uh then we will call you back or if
you want to write via email go to John
deloney.com ask a s k and don't forget
our gift to you we've partnered up with
Thorn which I think are some of the best
supplements on the market on the planet
t-h-o-r-n-e go to thorn.com you the
letter deloney for 25 off everything in
their or great supplements world-class
supplements are expensive and 25 off
makes a big big difference all right
let's go out to Charleston South
Carolina and talk to Isaac yo yo what's
up Isaac
hey man I'm as excited as opening day of
deer season I get to talk to the doctor
John deloney I uh the opening day of
deer season I don't talk to anybody just
the woods
hey man I'm doing good I appreciate you
taking taking the time to talk with me
and everything that y'all do up here at
Ramsey Solutions uh y'all y'all really
do help people with hope and change
lives so I'm really grateful I'm a big
fan thank you my brother thank you thank
you what's up
well uh my question was about resentment
um you know
you know once once you're there uh can
you come back
um and if so how um I know the should I
come back is up to me but you know
coming back from it and maybe House
shows so I can certainly provide a
little more context yeah I I think
coming out of the gate knowing I'm
always gonna answer that question yes
and it's hard
right if you are in disgust and contempt
and resentment
I mean you're talking a control alt
delete on just about everything
um to come back together is it possible
100 absolutely so tell me what happened
how do we get here all right
well
um been married to my wife but this is
going on seven years
um we've been separated since March
early March
um but uh you know circling back to that
we got we got three kids under five
um so you know we've our marriage has
been raising kids for the most part
um short timeline we had a big job
change and a move back in July
um come August took a trip home and had
a little uh there's a falling out with
my parents and I didn't quite stand up
for her maybe as best as I could have
but um you know things started kind of
getting a little stressful from there
um and then come October she came to me
saying she wanted uh basically to start
separation process and things
came came clean about some infidelity
from years back
um that I didn't know about
um including with one of my really close
friends and groomsmen
um so that was that was a big shock and
um I was willing you know I wanted to
work with with her from there
forgiveness all that you know I was good
there and wanted to do everything I
could to keep what we had together
um and then you know it was kind of
going through that back and forth
process feeling like I was trying
everything I could then come January I
uh found out she was actually currently
uh being unfaithful with one of my very
close friends and co-workers
um so
yeah that was just another another
dagger in the back that um you know got
Twisted basically but so from that point
you know felt like I felt like I had a
direction I was going
um you know like I said parted ways in
March she's living elsewhere you know a
few miles down the road you know we
still have close relationship obviously
with our three kids and everything
um but uh just a few weeks ago she comes
back and
uh it ready to rated
realize she did wrong and wants to fix
things and um honestly this is this is
only one of the few times in my life
where I uh I really just don't know what
to do um really just at a loss
um as far as how I feel and what to feel
so if you and I were sitting out
um on opening day in the woods
and they were sitting in a two-person
tree stand which means we are about two
inches from each other
and it was quiet
and I looked over at you and said what
are you gonna do
without trying to filter it without
trying to think through yeah but what
would you say
um
you know
what would you say go with your gut just
say it like I want to
um you know I uh we uh
I want to
um that's you know that's what I want to
work towards but I just I just don't
know how um I'm gonna try something on
and you and you you rejected
wholeheartedly if I'm wrong okay
I think you are done
and I think you want to want to because
you think that's the right thing
and you have a picture in your head
about people who quote unquote quit and
when she circled back for a third time
after destroying your life
destroying the life of her kids
and destroying
um your friendships
that little voice that said well
now that she wants to be back in if you
walk away You're the quitter
and I think something in your spirit
says I'm done
and you don't know what to do next
because this is a scary terrifying
proposition because this is somebody you
built a life with you created a family
with and you don't have a plan B
and yet here we are
tell me if I'm wrong
uh I mean I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
completely wrong
um
it's
yeah like I don't want to be done but it
it just it just seems impossible to not
be done almost
um Have you listened to this show before
yeah yes I have so you know I'm always
telling people to to find a path back
together and this one just for whatever
reason man maybe it's because I normally
shoot shows in the morning and this
afternoon but there is something in my
spirit that just is is grossed out by
this whole thing
all right
um I usually
um
I I usually believe there are two sides
to every one of these stories
am I wrong here this one feels very very
one-sided
uh as far as the actions that were done
it was pretty one-sided I mean you know
obviously nobody's a perfect husband and
things like that I disagree I'm
incredible I'm just kidding of course of
course no one's perfect
but but I mean but let's be honest in
your whole life you've never been
married and a parent of a kid
you were I've never been married and the
parent of two kids never been married in
a parent of three kids so y'all are
constantly having to rebuild and rebuild
and rebuild and so nobody does that
right of course you make design
decisions that are goofy and you put the
you know you put a foundation footer in
the wrong place that's just part of
being married and figuring things out
together
that's not a reason to go hook up with
somebody's best friend
and then lie about it
and make you feel crazy
that's not it's not Liberty to do it
again and it's funny when you were
telling me that my first thought was oh
she's practicing on him
she's practicing telling an old store to
see if it's okay to tell what's really
going on right now
right
and lo and behold
so here's I'm gonna tell you if you want
to stay married to her you can stay
married to her this isn't resentment I
don't think I don't think you're there
yet this is Active Pain
resentment is when the smoke is cleared
and you realize oh we're not even in the
same house anymore
psychologically emotionally spiritually
we are two different we have two
different lives you're not there yet man
you're still bleeding
right
she destroyed your family and I'm sorry
appreciate you appreciate you saying
that and you know
yeah I mean it's tough
um it really is and
um what do you do for a living
uh I'm a wildlife biologist okay all
right very cool
um
yeah
I'll say this as delicately as I can you
can't fix this
right this is and I can't I just can't
fix her and I know that like that but
your marriage can't be quote unquote
fixed
it will have to be rebuilt from the
floor up
yeah and you for the first time and you
haven't done this in 10 years you're
gonna have to be very clear about what I
need
and
and she's gonna have to be very
empathetic towards those needs and be so
focused with like a laser beam on
empathy with you
I don't think she's got to enter
unless she has just seen the light
right
and rightly or wrong I I you know I'm I
might be out to lunch with this but for
whatever reason I grade these kind of
things on a on a scale
and what I mean by that is somebody sits
down and says hey dude I was on a
business trip we were all at a dinner
and there was a couple of salesmen a
couple I don't know what happened but I
hooked up with somebody
um that's stupid and that's painful it's
hurtful
that's not hooking up with my husband's
best friend
no and this was once once found out it
was
continued on and found it and then and
then and then again
that's almost pathological
it's disgusting
and so when I'm thinking through like
man you bring forgiveness back I don't
know what happened I screwed up I got I
there was a month when I was just head
over heels with somebody at work and
what those things happen that's life
this is this is something different and
so I want you to hear me say you aren't
crazy
and you're not over feeling this thing
and you're not a bad guy for thinking
for starting to make plans of what comes
next in the world that you are now cast
into by yourself you're not crazy you're
not a bad guy
okay
right you're a guy that was legitimately
done wrong
and I think the question is
what does co-parenting look like what
does friends look like
um can I ask you a real sensitive
question
absolutely when's the last time y'all
were together intimately when's the last
time you slept together
uh probably
either back September
um except yeah before I knew about the
first stuff so because we were you know
kind of separate rooms type stuff like I
said from kind of September into August
the Joven had like a hook up one night
or a hey I miss you kind of thing
dropping the kids off or something
no
okay
yeah man I'm sorry
when you if you decide I'm out I'm done
my kids deserve better I deserve better
she's got a lot of healing to do and I'm
not the person that I can't I can't drag
her through it
it's gonna hit you like a tsunami the
pain the reality of all of this
and
I don't want you to run from that okay
all right
you're gonna have to get a couple of
guys in your life you're not gonna have
to head into the storm you can't run
from this one man this just sucks
yeah I am I am blessed in my life you
know I've got I mean that's
considering everything that's happened
of I feel like I'm in a good place I've
got good people around me um you know
being in the new place still working on
working on new people around here but
I've I've got good people in my life and
that's good
um
they haven't stuck the dagger in my back
yet hey the first one the first one you
told him I said hey man you know
pressure's on you now you know
he said man I ain't gonna I don't even
know if I can call you on the phone no
more hey that's that's actually
I can't imagine how awkward you could
make a like hanging out with a couple of
new guys and y'all get to be good
friends and be like all right listen
if any one of you guys sleeps with my
wife I'm gonna kill you right I can
imagine dinner getting kind of strange
um
here here's here's the deal I want you
to hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
uh just something for you to read
through and it's it's just the path out
man of sitting in this grief and what do
I do and where do I head
um where do I go now
I'm not gonna hate you I'm Not Gonna
Roll my eyes at you I'm gonna hug you if
you say nope we talked we had an honest
come to Isaac conversation we're going
to stay together great
and if you want to do that both of you
call me back I'll walk you through the
path back that y'all can start
um if you decide man this thing's been
done since September
um it's been on life support but it's
been gone since September I'm done
spark is gone this guy's just gone
Fire's out and um
if you want to do that call me back man
and we can figure out where to go from
there I want you to never feel like you
don't have anybody to call or a place to
go
um or a place to turn
I'm just heartbroken for you man
sorry that your wife did this to you
and she blew everything up
take care of take care of Isaac take
care of those little ones
we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with the licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's a better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to Knoxville and
talk to Shea what's up Shay
hey how are you doing we are partying
what are you up to that's not true I'm
not I'm not I'm just at work what are
you doing
oh just living a dream
anytime somebody says they're living the
dream they are for sure not living the
dream what's going on
I I've had a dream not the dream
excellent good good word right there all
right so what's up
I am
really struggling with motherhood and
specifically
getting over stimulated and overwhelmed
with my kids and all the
responsibilities that come with it and
I'm just looking for
any help any way that I can work through
that I love my kids of course with
everything for the rest of the show you
don't even have to repeat that because I
know that I know you love them
okay
um over stimulation with moms is kind of
a Hot Topic right now tell me tell me
what that means to you
do you have kids I do right you know
I'm sure anyone who's seen a small child
in a busy area
you get overwhelmed by the sights and
the sounds and the noises and they get
cranky and they start fussing and having
issues I feel like that as an adult
I
have a hard time with the noises one of
my kids constantly moves never stops
running never stops climbing fidgeting
the other one cannot stop talking
he talks a mile a minute he is probably
a hundred thousand words a day
constantly
and so between the sounds and the
movement and
then do you walk through can you walk
through your kitchen and you feel little
things under your feet
so constantly and then you step on your
truck or a Lego and there's a crumb than
a thing and it's all it's like sensory
overload
it is all the time and I don't want to
be overloaded with my kids and with
motherhood of course I I get I either
get to the point where I'm so hyper
focused on everything that's going on or
I completely shut down yeah and my kids
deserve better than that
I wouldn't say better they deserve
different
okay
is that cool
yeah okay
um so what's the
what's the core message
that you feel in your chest like a
ticker tape at the bottom of like a Fox
News or CNN or something like that
what is the core message
of a mom with two Wily little kids
when you have a kid that won't stop
talking you have a kid that's just kind
of running around everywhere and
tripping and falling and there's crumbs
and there's rappers
and there's what is that core message in
your chest what are you what are you
telling yourself
I'm guessing I'm failing there it is
and what's beneath I'm failing
what's the message beneath that one
it's probably the one you've been
sitting on since you were a little bitty
girl
it's not good enough yeah worthless
I'm freaking worthless and here's guest
exhibit number
144.
can't even keep my kids fill in the
blank and then that's followed by
what kind of mom doesn't even like her
own kids
Fair
yeah
and then your sweet body
spins up trying to take care of you and
it runs as fast as it can until it
collapses then it spins back up and runs
as fast as it can until it collapses
are you married
I am then knucklehead comes home and
starts pawing at you and you're like
God if you touch me I'm gonna kill you
and you kind of like some conversation
but you kind of like sleeping with them
and then you think what kind of ma wife
am I that won't even sleep with this
great what's the Met right
yeah absolutely touched out is the word
we use in my household yep what's the
word
touchdown
so instead of that touch being a safe
place like a like a place that you can't
wait to get to it's a place that makes
you feel like you're electrified
mm-hmm
so I want you to think of your body as
doing its best job to protect you
and it's been protecting you from this
core message that you're you're not
worth much or anything
for a long long time
I talk to people all over the country
that get that mess got that message from
their Church growing up
that you were such a worthless
disgusting creature
that God had to murder his kid so that
your disgustingness could right that was
part of the narrative or it could have
been from Dad could have been from Mom
Are you seriously going to wear that it
would have killed you to get one more a
really oh my gosh gross eat that he
never stopped
and this core message is you're not good
enough you're not good enough you're not
good enough
and then and then marriage is going to
rescue us right we're gonna find that
guy who loves us do you feel safe with
him
so I'm gonna ask you something weird a
Common Thread and it's not always so
tell me I'm wrong I'm wrong
but a common response to the message of
I'm worthless
when you find somebody that you feel
safe with your body actually kind of
slows down a little bit with
you overdo it with them to the point
that they're like God you're a lot and
they say it in their nice kind way
because that's usually those kind of
people
and you feel it when they go ah and then
they try to re jump the bridge through
sex am I onto something
I think so I think that sounds real
familiar
actually your husband called me and like
filled me in on everything and you're
I'm just kidding not even a little bit
no that wouldn't surprise me it's okay
so here's here's the goal here
the goal is not to be less over
stimulated
and I know that sounds bananas
over stimulation is your body trying to
get your attention Okay we don't protect
our houses from burning down by taking
all the smoke detectors out
what we want to do is address that core
message
that yet again you're not worth anything
and it's not true
that's the that's the that's the problem
with it is it's not true it's a lie it's
false
and so we are going to begin a practice
where when our body starts taking off on
us
we're gonna catch it we're gonna have
somebody that we trust that could be
your husband that could be your A
girlfriend of yours that could be
um
um your mom if she's safe she probably
is not based on your story
um it could be a a counselor whatever
but all we're going to do is when we
feel our body when one kid's running
around and you say stop running and they
just keep running and instantly that's
it right there your body dumps into your
own kid won't even listen to you
yeah wait a way to be nice mom
and then you yell or snap and then
you're like ah and you're a terrible mom
too
we're just gonna stop right there and
we're literally gonna put our hand on
our chest and we're gonna feel our
bodies
and we're going to Exhale really deep
and say
that's not true
I'm not a terrible mom
I'm exhausted
ta-da I get to be exhausted not terrible
I am not worthless and we're going to be
really intentional about I am statements
I am a good wife
and I am a great mom
and I am working to practice on some new
things that I've never done before in my
life
do you hear how one of these is so much
more peaceful than going to war
absolutely
so
here's a couple of weird things I want
you to practice okay
okay and you're not going to find this
in traditional parent literature
um in there so they're kind of weird
number one I want you to practice
not using your kids as a report card
okay
here's what that means your kid does
something ridiculous like knocks over a
plate of chips in a restaurant or yells
real loud I don't want you to look
around and make eye contact with other
people
I want you to feel your body kind of
getting embarrassed and ashamed and oh
my gosh and then go he's two you know
what two-year-olds do knock over chip
bowls
next time I is the adult I'm just going
to remember to move the chips
ta-da no war no fight no running no body
starting to try to defend me because
there's nothing to defend I'm just gonna
remember to move the chips next time
when somebody says man this one's got a
lot of energy
let your first impulse I want you to
practice this be thank God
it's so great
it's a lot but it's so great
do you see what I'm saying we're
practicing new ways of doing that okay
and you're going to stumble and fall and
trip and screw up and be like oh gosh
he's the worst then you're gonna catch
yourself be like he can be the worst but
man I'm glad these health and he's
running around and we're just gonna
practice that okay here's the second one
and when I say this I don't want you
just to immediately run into a big ball
of burning shame okay that sounds like
an old uh My Chemical Romance song but I
don't want you to be like it's a ball of
Shame
okay okay
I want you to practice
being likable
and here's what I mean by being likable
not being a doormat not having feelings
that's not what I mean
whenever you find yourself about to tell
your kid to stop running around I want
you to ask yourself why
why am I deciding that this is an
important Hill is he unsafe then yeah of
course
and instead of yelling I'm just gonna
get up and pick him up
or
I have this picture that a perfect mom
has perfect kids and perfect kids don't
move they don't run around they don't
ask questions they don't talk too much
and that's not true
perfect kids are
silly and rambunctious and quiet and
loud in some sleep and some aren't very
good at sleeping it's a it's just a
bunch of different pictures
and so
when I say practice being likable
practice skipping every other
hey stop hey quick quick hey quit asked
can you just put skip every one of those
or when one of your kids starts talking
I want you like you can put your hand up
and go or put your hand on them and say
hey mom needs seven minutes
when this clock says one four two
I want to hear all about your story
and you're gonna have three minutes I
want you to tell me the whole story
are you ready and they'll go yeah
and then you take those seven minutes
and you breathe and you go and you go ah
and some of that chatter will have
dissipated and there will be a core
story there that you can hold your kids
hands squat down and look them in the
eye and say tell me all about it and now
your body's not trying to do 48 things
at once it's just lasered in here and
you're gonna find that that kid isn't as
knowing as you think it is think he or
she is
and all we're doing we're just
practicing being likable
and with your husband there's a way that
you can push and push and push until you
snap we're just going to go way Upstream
and you're gonna he's gonna ask you
every morning what's the best way I can
love you today
and what you're gonna find in a couple
of weeks or a couple of months is man if
you do bedtimes or help with bedtimes
and if you just see a dish in the sink I
have a strange thing about dishes in the
sink or whatever the thing is for you
um
you are going to have more peace and
he's gonna have a lot more sex and you
are too obviously see what I'm saying
yes okay so I threw a lot at you I want
to hear back from you
you may have you may be like dude John
I've done all of these things or this
may be totally new tell me what you're
feeling as I'm talking
my husband and I just recently had that
conversation actually okay
um my product of listening to your show
all the time
okay tell me how that conversation went
did not start off as a calm conversation
but we
the more we talked about
our individual needs not being met we
figured out that
if our needs aren't being met we don't
want to meet the other ones mean there
you go and so we are both trying to make
a more concerted effort
and helping the other one get what they
want and what they need
that that is beautiful here's my here's
my mechanics question how did y'all set
that up did you tell him a list of needs
that you have and he told you a list
yes okay I want to change that a little
bit okay
okay needs are very Dynamic what I mean
by Dynamic is they're different all the
time they're always moving
so I want you to come up with a regular
morning practice where you ask each
other how can I help meet your needs
today how can I love you best today
because some days you're going to be
like I want to do the dishes and not
look at another human or talk
and he may walk in and do all the dishes
he's like I do all the dishes so you can
have more time with the kids and you're
like I'm gonna go bury myself in the
backyard
right so I want this needs conversation
to be something y'all do every single
day
and what you're going to find is just
the intimacy of this conversation
is going to be extraordinary
and you're going to find that some days
you have this need some days you have
that need some days he has this need
some days you have that need
you might just have a picture of he
needs more sex okay so you're just gonna
have a picture of sex a picture of sex
well he may want rambunctious
silly we just got like
can't wait to get home sex and then
other days he may want to just
sit with you and have old like
connection boring married sex like what
it's gonna be different every time and
so I want y'all to make this a practice
is that fair
yeah absolutely all right I want you to
say out loud
I'm worthy of being a wife and I'm
worthy of being a mom
worthy is being a mom
and I want you to say out loud I am not
worthless
I am not worthless
that story is not true
say it
is that hard to say
there it is yeah
so when you get up the courage to call a
counselor that's going to be where we
start
my core story
my core message
that I tell myself on a regular bit it's
encoded into my DNA is that I'm
worthless
and I've tried to achieve academically
and I've tried to achieve I've fallen
the rules or I've tried to get people's
attentions by drinking a lot or I've
tried to marry the perfect guy and had
the perfect kids
and the underlying ticker tape story is
over and over and over again
you are worthless what are you doing
here just go just leave and that story
is a lie
[Music]
it's the roots of that story that we
feel
[Music]
we begin to think through new things
then we begin to practice new ways of
real life
[Music]
and hey let's be honest if you get a
house cleaner
tell your husband to vacuum that may
help too we'll be right back
all right let's go out to Wisconsin and
talk to Brett what is up Brett
hey John how you doing oh good I thought
this was Brett Favre and so good
I was actually named after him of course
but never played football I just assumed
85 percent of Wisconsin is walking
around named Brett at some point
followed by Aaron is the other name
yeah yeah so what's up dude
um so I have a question for you
um how do I rebuild a solid relationship
with my family after losing trust with
them in the past what'd you do
so
um last year uh right before Christmas
actually I went through kind of a
breakup you know it was um kind of kind
of somewhat my fault I was a little bit
of like you know a closet drinker in a
way
um and um so there was like no trust so
it was kind of like uh
um
kind of like okay I understood but I
I've never really been good with dealing
with my emotions so
um I just kind of led to drinking a lot
um but the big thing that happened was
uh
um I ended up going on like a week and a
half long Bender uh in front of my
family
and uh it just it's Totten I'm ashamed
of and you know they tell me they love
me and and everything but it's just it's
more of like a my problem that I have a
hard time like believing that
um and I was kind of wondering like
should I sit down with them should I
um like it wasn't like cousins or aunts
or uncles it was like parents and
brothers
um what did you did you do some some
things that you regret were you on a
bender
um
yeah I'd say so like I was kind of like
swearing in front of my parents which I
never do that
um and like just like I stole their car
you know went to the car with it lead
with that dude
I I got I had a bender and I stole my
parents car that's where we it's like
well I said some bad words
dude incredible
um yeah no I like honestly um it's been
a few months so I laugh about it now it
I guess my dad didn't see it that way
yeah but I just I wanna be able to like
um I don't know if I should like sit
down and apologize with them
individually and and all that you know
so I just kind of want to know your
thoughts on that
um
well there's a lot here
and I say there's a lot here because
you didn't just
all of a sudden become a closet drinker
and all of a sudden
not feel safe talking through how you
were feeling about things or being able
to express emotions in a healthy way
yeah and my guess is that same love that
same
like
and well and also you didn't just
overnight become a guy who lied to
somebody that he loved and cared about
about his health and his drinking and
his inability to be in contact with his
emotions or feelings
like that's a long history worth of life
so my question for you would be how much
of this originates in that same family
that saw you come Unwound
um like my parents don't drink at all
that doesn't matter at all in fact that
can that can sometimes I don't see it
make it worse but
they're they're going to decompress
somehow
and it may have been on you
okay see what I'm saying
do you uh could you maybe elaborate on
that like a little bit yeah so
let's say your parents didn't drink
let's say they were suit I'm gonna make
something up here okay I don't know
let's say they were super super strict
religious people
and they had a core set of rules
one of which was you never drink
and you never swear
and real people of character and
morality and whatever Faith tradition
fill in your faith tradition of choice
here
people who are
gonna make it in the end don't do this
and this and this and this and this
and then Brett's just a kid
and Brett does a kid thing
and becomes
um
sacrificed on the altar of those seven
or eight or ten or forty different
things that we don't do
we're not allowed to do
and at some point the rules become the
favorite child
the way we are the facade that we wear
is more important
then making sure Brett knows
a brother there is my son there is there
is nothing
you can do that I won't come get you
there is nowhere to go that I won't
still love you
that's not the message the message is
you do these 42 things right then we'll
allow you to sit here
and you know a great proxy for
relationship a great proxy for love
chemically speaking is alcohol
it is a a young boy's body screaming for
somebody to connect with me
because my parents are connecting with
their rule set
over me
and so alcohol works man
it works oh yeah I know I believe yeah
so
and then one day you can't hold it in
anymore and it the Dam breaks and the
water bursts forth because you finally
found somebody to plug into
and she left to
yeah no I just made up a whole scenario
just made it up okay any that ring true
or you can be like you're kind of an
idiot no no no
um I uh I think a lot of it um started
um
when I was probably 18 and like kind of
getting involved in like construction no
no no what happened before that
you you played along before that in what
way
I didn't really like drink no I don't
care about alcohol you're focused on
alcohol I'm not I'm focusing on ways
your body
got to the next day
what were your coping strategies
before alcohol yep
um or let me say it like this
Straight A's can be a trauma response
too
yeah being I guess um
go ahead
maybe like um I don't know like I always
um
I always like to be the best
you know
um I guess and I always
sometimes maybe like I would try to
please people
I don't know uh
I guess I I can't
um like think of an example of like in
my childhood that I felt
um the need to feel that okay
um but um I mean like we were
um I don't know like things were
um you know that's just how I like to be
you know and
yeah I guess I I'm not really sure you
know so let's let's transition to where
we are now
how did you apologize or have you
apologized after what happened at
Christmas
uh we no and that's um yes then you need
you need to get in a car and go sit with
your mom and dad
okay and if you have brothers or sisters
there you need to look across the table
but do not go unless two things are true
number one you have a plan to stop
drinking for good
okay and you are able to demonstrate mom
and dad I don't drink I've been going to
this these meetings I've been seeing
this counselor I got in over my head and
I became somebody I was not
here are the steps I have taken
and not because you're going to love me
more
but I need you all to know that your
little boy is going to be okay
that's number one number two
don't go apologize until you mean it and
what I mean is don't go apologize to
make yourself feel less guilty
because then you're using them for to
prop you up don't do that
okay go apologize to them because you
hurt them
and yeah you're gonna feel sad and
you're gonna feel very sorry and you're
going to feel disconnected and that's
all right it's good
because you are
you messed up
yeah
um yeah no I I appreciate that so that
helps out a lot the third thing I want
you to do here is
I don't want you to try to solve it for
them
I want you to ask them
Mom Dad brother sister I love you
then I'm open to whatever it takes to
make this right
and this is submission this is you
taking a knee
and that's going to be hard for you
because you're going to think well what
if they tell me this or what if they say
I can never yep
it's part of restoring relationships and
if they give you something and they say
we want you to do this this and this
you're like are you doing that cool then
you are choosing to walk away from this
relationship but I don't think that's
your heart I don't think that's where
you are
no no definitely not I it was actually
like the one
um kind of it was kind of like the one
thing that like the one way I was that
I'd never like wanted my parents to ever
see me like you know blacked out drunk
you know and like do things like that
and you know like saying things in front
of my brother that I really didn't you
know like kind of an example like I was
my brother doesn't really call me a lot
and I was like in front of them and he
was kind of telling me like
um you know we love you and stuff and I
was like oh you never call me you never
do any of this and I I think he kind of
felt bad but I didn't really wanna
I didn't know if I needed to like tell
them that way you know what I mean so
um yeah I think it's as simple as
telling some folks
I got real real drunk and I did some
things and said some things that are
gonna haunt me for the rest of my life
and I need you to look you all in the
eye and tell you I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I hurt the people that love me the most
okay and I had a problem with alcohol
here's the steps I'm taking
I had a problem with lying and
dishonesty here's the steps I'm taking
from this point forward here's who I am
going to be
not here's who I'm not here's who I am
and then just know that any one of them
could say ask for you
they probably won't
but if you've ever listened to this show
you know I always say every relationship
is a risk everyone is a risk so when you
go to repair a relationship after you've
hurt somebody
they can say I don't I'm I'm done you
broke the circle I'm out
and they get to do that and it's gonna
hurt
but at least at the end of it all you
did the right thing
you you retained dignity and respect
even after doing things that were not
dignified and was not honoring of people
you did the next right thing
then you took a knee and said I hope
you'll still love me
my guess is they're gonna say thank God
we do
this is part of growing up and it's the
worst part man
but in person go make the visit
don't do this on the phone don't do this
via text
if you gotta fly pay for the ticket on
your own and go fly
it's time to make this right
it's time to make this right we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey we're back
with some sad news just got noticed just
a few minutes ago Tina Turner passed
away the Great and Mighty Tina Turner so
as a shout out to her
um Kelly does not have a Tina Turner
tattoo because she is not cool enough
she actually went to the tattoo parlor
to get one and the tattoo gun would not
fire the tattoo that is fair because I
think you have to be
pretty badass for Tina Turner yeah
that's a that's a level that I aspire to
you'll get there you're on
a middling uh health and wellness
podcast just just keep on keep watching
any day now any day
um the song is a Tina Turner Classic
What's Love Got to Do with it and it
goes like this
you must understand though the touch of
your hand makes my pulse react
that it's only the thrill of boy meeting
girl Opposites Attract it's physical
only logical you must try to ignore that
it means more than that
What's Love Got to Do with It
what's love but a second hand emotion
What's Love Got to Do With It who needs
a heart when a heart can be broken
I've been taking on a new Direction but
I have to say I've been thinking about
my own protection it scares me to feel
this way
[Music]
shout out Tina pour some out
we'll see you soon